it's not everyday we've been getting
rain in California so when we get it in
LA I want to take advantage of mommy see
the green aback beautiful in it look at
the green look at the green I love it
yes it's raining we got a love this
weather we're having but I had something
on my mind I wanted to share with you a
friend of my call me a year ago and he
said he had this idea to start his own
business and he would like to be
mentored now I'm in the financial
services business I run my own financial
firm with leaders and partners that we
have and he had nothing to do with this
business he couldn't get involved in the
business because of his background in
certain issues that he had but he says
he wants me to mentor him I said no
problem
so I said well what do you have in mind
he says well you know I haven't worked
for this many years and I want to get
into it etc etc and I challenged him and
he said I want you to mentor me I said
no problem so we sat down and I
challenged him on what he needed to do
and what suggestions I had and he says
you know why are you challenging me so
hard and I said I'm sorry I didn't
approach you to mentor you you
approached me to be mentored right he
said yes I said so what is your
interpretation of what a mentor is and
it says well I'm just thinking you're
going to motivate me you know and tell
me I can do it I said that you have a
rough interpretation of what a mentor is
because that's not a mentor I don't have
a mentors actually do a lot less
motivating if you want a motivational
speaker go pay 500 bucks go watch a
motivational speaker motivate you for
you know day or two and you know maybe
that'll help you out you know if you
want to be hiring a motivational speaker
go watch some of these you know
recordings or whatever it is just to get
motivated but a mentor is a different
story and mentors are not in a game of
just motivating and injecting belief
although that is a natural trait of
theirs but mentors only become mentors
because they're just motivated matter if
they're motivated matter of fact they
actually motivate a lot less because
they're more about challenging so he
went away and we didn't talk for about
six months and he came back and I he
wanted
money at first I said this is I'm now
going to give you money because you
don't have a track record of success but
I can mentor you if you want me to any
walked away and came back one day we say
says ok I'm ready it's a great said if
you haven't read this if you haven't
read that book if you haven't read this
book I'm not meeting with you and he
said when you read this book I said
again it seems like we keep going back
and forth with this and you want to be
able to figure out how to become an
entrepreneur and successful and make
money without actually doing the work
and it's not going to happen that way so
many people want to be millionaires and
make money and have a great lifestyle
and live in a nice place and travel and
see the world and they don't see the
behind-the-scenes thing and he says oh
you know I'm not good with reading and
I'm not good with this now I said listen
you're talking to a guy who had a
terrible GPA in high school who in high
school teachers would make fun of my
reading my peers would laugh at me and I
was never read I can't stand reading but
I can't stand being broke and being
controlled by media and other people
that are you know constantly
manipulating us through TV I want to
control my life with mentors that could
challenge me to improve so every mentor
I have they challenge 90% at a time and
they you know motivate 10% of the time
it's not the other way around and the
higher you go actually the motivating
goes lower and lower and lower it
doesn't go higher and higher and higher
the higher you move up in life it's a
lot less motivation you're going to get
because you're going to be a lot longer
as you move up because there's a lot of
room at the top so if you ask yourself
how many strong mentors do you have who
go out of their way to challenge you and
push you you can only answer that if you
don't have a lot of them here's why you
know how well think about it this well I
put it in the best way possible so maybe
this critics you know makes sense you
know last week I've read seven books I
finished seven books on the last week I
just can't stop reading last seven this
last week has just been non-stop and
we've had so much going on with a
conference that's coming up next week
with you know twelve thirteen hundred
people that are going to be with us in
Las Vegas and you know we have so many
different things we're putting up it's
going to be a four-day Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday event
that we'll have but
reading these books this weekend just a
lot of writing a lot of you know
reflecting and not a lot of sleep in
this past we've just been a lot of
thinking and when you think about
mentors think about back when we were
kids okay and I want you to think about
this when we were kids
and when mommy and daddy we typically
had one of our parents that if they
asked us what did you do with this
person and no parent is perfect but what
you do with what you do here well why'd
you get in trouble and then if we told
the truth what would normally happen
right think about that well mom you know
I hit him in the face
you did what you hit him you're ground
above me like I'm never gonna tell this
one with the truth again right what do
you do mom I I smoke this or I drank
this right that what did you do some pot
you know and then you get in trouble for
telling the truth so what eventually
happens is when you respond to someone
who's telling the truth with that kind
of a reaction guess what you start
attracting in your life a bunch of liars
because people don't want to tell you
the truth anymore
they prefer lying to you than telling
you the truth so you are attracting
Liars in your life who tell you what you
want to hear not what you need to hear
because you're attracting liars and
people want to make you feel good
because you don't like it when people
tell you the truth just like our parents
they don't like it when we told them to
truth you know in parenting uh you know
my father had a very simple approach if
I told them the truth I didn't get
anything nothing bad happening just
Satmar would you learn from Walker I
always told him tribe never been if I've
told my dad things that he probably
never wanted to hear if I told them and
I think the same is with mentorship the
same as with leadership the same is with
you wanting a mentor in your life the
reason why no one is telling you the
truth
to challenge you is because you would
rather have a liar as a mentor who just
makes you feel good maybe like a mother
or
friend or girlfriend or you know of
whoever somebody that just was your
grandmother your grandfather that always
told you to good things that's not what
mentors do so if you truly want by the
way that same God that I talked about my
friend he made $27,000 last month
having nothing to do with business he
does not have a degree he barely
graduated from high school May 27
thousand dollars last month in his
business and he and his wife they're
getting another house they're planning
on having another kid and he just can't
stop reading he's working he's excited
about life and this you would have never
believed it with this guy I mean none of
our friends would have ever believed I'm
so proud of this guy for what he's doing
but he finally understood when he and I
have a conversation I tell him I say
don't ask me this question until you
read these three chapters in this book
great then he calls me back because I
don't need to ask you the question why
not cuz he already got the answer
perfect so now he knows questions he
wants answered I reference into certain
videos he needs to watch a certain
article he needs to watch but he is
finally willing to attract people who
are being who are willing to be honest
with them instead of lying so ask
yourself the question do you attract
liars in your life and do you create
people in your life who lied to you
because they would prefer to light you
then tell the truth and how do you react
when a mentor tells you the truth do you
just kind of want to beat them up and
just kind of get away and that mentor
says because mentor we're going to leave
and say no I'm gonna go mentor someone
else cuz I don't I don't you I didn't
choose to mentor as you said you wanted
a mentor so this whole notion about
wanting a mentor and I want somebody
successful to mentor me because I want
to have a nice life and I want to listen
before I had this house and whatever
backyard were looking at here and you
know all this stuff that we got before
this I was living in a shack in a place
that used to be drive-bys one night I
came home there were guys outside with
knives waiting for me and we got into a
pretty bad fight and I had to get to
work the next day and my dad calls me at
11 o'clock saying come home because
there's 20 guys waiting for you outside
this was before I was 21 22 23 and I
wanted to get out of that environment
and back that you don't see it my wife
and two
my dad they're my kids are playing with
their grandpa right now we're making
food and we're going to have some
whatever and hang out and have a good
time but it's a byproduct of many many
mentors who were not afraid of telling
me the truth and I was not afraid of
hearing the truth and knowing their
track record that they had won it wasn't
somebody I paid $1,000 because this
guy's going to you know and sometimes
you hire these consultants that you
think these consultants are going to
change your life oh I'm gonna pay this
guy ten thousand dollars remember
consultants are never going to rarely
going to tell you the truth do you know
why because typically if they tell you
the truth guess what may happen to them
they may lose a customer you know when
you hire a personal trainer personal
trainer is very rarely pushed to the
highest levels do you know why because
they're afraid of losing a customer
because you're paying them 200 bucks an
hour or you know 50 bucks an hour 100
whatever the personal trainer rate is
you know 150 bucks 20 bucks an hour
you're paying them so they can't really
push until you're out of shape you're
this your duck is going to lose them but
if you want to really kill or mentor be
prepared for strong mentors to make you
feel very uncomfortable quite regularly
and be prepared for them to push you in
a way nobody else has pushed you before
and be irritated by them at times and if
you don't want one believe me they're
okay with that strong mentors are okay
with that but if you do want one that
comes with the territory anyways this is
the rain we have in California we get it
for five ten minutes it goes away but we
have some green right now because it's
been raining a little bit lately look at
that beautiful huh all the green we have
in our backyard I love it there's
something about the green that you gotta
love anyways hey I'm on twitter as well
Patrick bad David you can see it on the
link below if you got any questions I do
respond on Twitter if you put comments
on the bottom as well I do respond as
well for those of you out there that
have a strong mentor who pushes you
bothers you irritates you be thankful
for him or her because if you keep
wanting him to lie to you mentors strong
mentors don't know how to lie they
simply won't spend time with you
you know cherish your mentors share this
video with your mentor and tell them
thank you for being a tough mentor with
me anyways have a good one
we'll talk to you soon and take you
everybody buh bye